what is up everybody welcome to another
python tutorial this tutorial is going
to be a twofer so you're going to get
not only how to search google the
quote-unquote easy way but also coverage
of the json functionality within python
so we've really only
dealt with json
data structure one other time and that
was with the twitter feed and we just
used simple splitting functions to do it
uh but there is this fancy dancy json
modules that we can use so we're going
to do that in this video
as well
so to start um we'll just show you guys
an example here of the uh
the api that google offers for searching
so head over to your favorite internet
browser which i assume is chrome
otherwise i don't know what you're doing
in my channel
uh and cop well i'll put the link in or
this link in the description so copy and
paste that in there and you can put
literally anything you want you can put
python tutorials and it's going to
return to you
a json output of data for the for python
tutorials as the search query
now your browser does this encoding
automatically for you
it depends really on whose api you're
using
sometimes it it doesn't work and then
other times you can just put anything in
there and it just automatically encodes
it
i'm going to show you guys how to encode
that data
but with this you you don't have to i
have no idea i would think that that
is something like i'm not sure how as a
web developer you could
not have to have the people using url
encoding so i don't know i don't know
enough about that stuff but anyways what
i do know is the safest bet is to always
use url encoding uh then you won't have
to worry about it
so
uh with that uh to do url encoding
you're gonna need import url lib not url
lib2 url lib
uh along that note if anybody knows how
to do url encoding with url lib 2
let me know i have no idea i've tried to
look for it and there like just seems to
be no way to do it so i always if i use
them both i import url lib and url lib2
so if anybody knows if any fine
gentleman or a lady happens to know
please leave a comment below and let me
know i am genuinely curious
next we need uh the json module as well
so we're going to import
json and now let's go ahead and get
started so with this we can do uh
example
uh search so we're going to search for
something i'm going to say
geographic
sentiment analysis
and then i'm going to say encoded
equals url lib.quote
example search so if you don't know what
that's going to do
basically adds percent 20 for every
space and then if you have like special
characters it'll also change them so uh
let's just print encoded just so you
guys can see what i'm yippy app in a
boot
so that's the url uh or at least that
part encoded right just added this
percent 20s but at the same time if you
did something like uh like this right
and we print out the url encoding
uh it fixes it right so
in as you can see even in this url right
the url has a question mark and an
ampersand to denote variables right and
it's going to get those variables and
use them so if you have those things in
your url
um
you you obviously need to encode them
first
before you do it so just keep that in
mind so while i said that actually at
least with this api you don't have to
encode you could just slap this right in
there but if this was like you know
how do i do this or something like that
um
and you didn't use url in coding you're
going to find yourself uh in trouble so
anyways um
that's my my teaching for today
video over no um so now what we want to
do is
uh we don't need to print and code it
anymore now we're going to say raw data
so let's be like that raw output is
going to equal url
uh url lib.url
and we want to open up
this link here so i'm going to copy and
paste it and it's going to say query
equals i'm not sure why this equal sign
is there so i'm going to delete that
query is going to equal uh encoded right
so we'll come over here
query equals and then we do a plus
and oops encoded and then at the end of
this we want to do a read so i'd
actually read so the raw data is
straight up just like the nasty text
that you'll get
from there so now we want to use the
json
functionality so now we're going to say
json data
equals uh
json.loads
and we're going to do raw data so we'll
load in the raw data now the way the
json module is going to work is like an
array or a list rather i shouldn't say
array i always call them arrays i'm
sorry guys
so
this is a list
and it's a it's a multi-dimensional list
at the first dimension you have
basically like this this right here but
it's actually this whole thing and then
you would say within there the response
data
dimension contains
all of oops
basically all of
i'm trying to find where the end of it
would be like right here i sub wall here
so that's response data then inside that
uh you've got another list that's more
easily recognizable with this
bracket and you've got another dimension
so it's a multi-dimensional
list right so you treat it just like
that even though it doesn't look like it
to your eyeballs that's what the json
module is doing for you so
for example
we would say the actual results so let's
say search
results equals
json data
and oops and what element in json data
are we looking for well we're looking
for the element that calls itself
response data so literally the camel
cased response data so i just copied
that right and i went
paste so that is that first element and
now of that element what element of
response data are the search results
within well they're within
results
right so now we take just like you would
with an array you add some more brackets
or a list sorry
and you add results in there so now you
have
of the response data list we want the
the results uh information basically
so now
um you can see in here you've got all
kinds of data here
um as far as uh you know you've got you
unescaped url then you've got the
straight up url
um and then you have
um well i can't find it but okay
title
uh and then what the title is in this
case here right
um and so really most of what we're
going to be looking for we're not going
to pull out like if you wanted to get
like the meta description right that's
usually what's underneath the link if
you wanted to pull that um
you could but for now we just maybe want
to pull the actual title and then let's
actually pull the url that we would
visit if we wanted to visit it so to do
that um once we've pulled so those are
the search results right then what we
would say is is for
each result let's say er
in search results what do we want to do
well the title
is er
and then
for that you know so it's like each
little result in our search results of
results right so each
little block of results right that's
within there
um what do we want and that's going to
be so each block what do we care about
in that block so of that list that's
that block of results we want
title
and that will give us the title and then
link
is going to be uh er and it was
url
um so obviously title and then i just i
forgot see i'll just type in url
wow there's a lot of url but anyway
there's url and so on so
um so that's that so now we've got title
and link so now let's just go ahead and
print title
print link
and then we'll just uh do some print one
two three
three lines
one two three and we're all set
so what it's going to do is it's going
to visit a search for geographical
sentiment analysis
it's going to use the json to
or the json functionality to read the
json go into that response data list go
into the results list and then inside
that results list print out all the
titles and urls in order so now let's
save that and let's run that see if we
had any
typos and we didn't so as you can see um
geographical sentiment analysis by
sentex oh who'da thunk that was coming
anyway
so you can see the results now here is
the downside it only returns to you
four
results and that is why my friends we
have a searching google the easy way and
we have a searching google
the hard way
because for some people for results is
not enough
so
stay tuned for a searching google the
hard way tutorial otherwise if this
fills all of your needs
then congratulations so hopefully you
guys enjoyed
hopefully you guys learned something new
i taught you a couple new things
hopefully here besides possibly the json
module i suppose and again if anybody
happens to know how to encode urls with
url lib2 uh do be kind enough to let me
know
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until the next video